So with the hammer tube is that long cylinder, right?
The hammer tube is the long cylinder.
You don't even know if you have the hammer tube right on your skin.
The bulb really isn't right on your skin because the bulb is inside the plastic sheet.
Okay, so it doesn't make a difference.
Does it make a difference to have it on your bare skin or versus through a pair of pajamas?
I think the closer it is, the less things it has to go through, the more penetration you're going to get.
So for most people, put it right on your pajamas is just fine.
But if you want even greater penetration, then put it underneath your pajamas.
Is there a difference?
I don't know.
Is it measurable?
No, because we can't stick a meter inside your stomach to see the difference.
But I think, yes, I think that is a factor.
Now, I am.
I got a true knife is coming out with some updates that I was going to say something, but I can't.
Because I forgot she promised me not to say anything yet.
But I got a there are coming up with some updates that are going to come out in February.
So that's going to be exciting.
Yeah, that is.
Dr. Connors, including that the hammer ball with the crystal kind of light light.
So the crystal tube is another choice with the hammer tube that he came out with about a couple of years ago.
And he sent one to me to test.
Well, how do you test it?
It's better.
There's just no way to know.
So, you know, we haven't we haven't really used that one.
It's it's it's more expensive and I just don't know that it's any better.
So I just you know, we haven't we haven't done that.